so was I supposed to do anything for
this I've like never been interviewed
before oh it's really easy um okay
there's one how old are you 18
yeah sure senior yep do you have a
boyfriend you're my best friend and
really worried that you're gonna think
differently of me I am I like somebody
or whatever oh yeah hey mom my friend is
coming over oh are you from the school
yearbook yeah all of a sudden oh she's
scared why I don't know what if I say
the wrong thing should we do it like
they do in Europe how do we do it in
Europe
oh wait let me try again
just like what do we do me and what are
we doing here um nevermind
I'm answer that
who is that no way will you tell me
what's wrong I can tell something's
wrong I was feeling guilty cause it said
I didn't care about any of it anymore I
don't know what I'm doing either no
cliff come here tell me what you do I
know this whole thing's our fault
I'm sorry it's just like there's no way
she'll forgive me why are you being so
mean to me I'm just trying to collect
all the facts you I'm not comfortable
with this I feel like my daughter is
being accused of something the whole
school knows if these two hooked up okay
I was drunk hey don't look at them